oh
irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
turquie village de match anne ancienne
mattia ni patrie le saint girons le
petit vigneron qui fut massacrée pour
être chrétien il reste de cet endroit
d'où jaillit une grande partie de la
pensée chrétienne un petit village
pittoresque et ses fontaines
non
il reste aussi ce monde étonnant celui
des maisons troglodytes le vallon de
goarem et le corps âme à des actes de
sahiron c'est là que poursuivi iront se
cacha il fut découvert et on l'emmena
pour le tuer la d'innombrables cellules
de moines du monastère et d'église se
tiennent la tradition veut qu'ils
contiennent 365 églises et chapelles une
pour chaque jour de l'année environ 40
sont visibles et accessibles les autres
détruisent ou enfouis demeure
introuvable
une de ces chapelle sainte hélène les
constantes à saint thomas sainte onu
saint basile
église éventré que rien n'a épargné ni
l'homme ni le temps
voici l'église au pommier elmaleh qui
lie c'est toujours dans le ravin de
goarem
les peintures illustre le groupe de
décoration du cycle biblique
elles sont disposées sur les surface
délimitée par des bandeaux de teintes
ocre rouge
le style de ses peintures et souple et
les personnages ont de la vie
l'entrée à jérusalem
oh
la crucifixion
à gauche les saintes femmes
et d'autres saints dont on a
volontairement supprimé le regard
église de 40 lits qui lisent l'église
obscures
elle ne date que du xiiie siècle et est
de ce fait relativement récentes sont en
augmentation et fait des scènes de
l'évangile classés selon leur importance
liturgique et non plus selon leur ordre
chronologique la nativité
les mages leurs chevaux les berges et
les musiciens le baptême l'entrée à
jérusalem la scène et les apôtres
la table et ses détails cela s'explique
par la forte influence de byzance qui
s'exerce au xième siècle en cappadoce et
ainsi la tradition helléniste exerce son
influence par l'intermédiaire de byzance
mais nous voici rendus à présent aux
rues du village aux gestes quotidiens le
présent semble là bas est retiré du
passé
m
du passé aussi cette scène de moisson et
ce n'est heureusement pas le cas de
toutes les régions de turquie
car ici le blé est ramassé à la main
poignet par poignées voici une gerbe
oise
le grain est écrasé par ce procédé plus
primitifs un traîneau de bois unis en
dessous de galets tranchant puis le vent
c'est par le grain de la balle et non
sans peine le tour est joué
à trois kilomètres de gorée mais orba
issard suivons cette caravane nous
sommes sûrs de nous y rendre
orbaiz arts village dominé par un énorme
rocher qui ajoute 40 mètres acquis
greffe de cheveux
ce qui pour l'instant est notre cas on y
cultive on y cueille et on sèche les
abricots devant vos yeux et sur le toit
des maisons
voilà symphonie parfaite fait d'odeurs
et de couleurs
oh
les églises rupestres de cappadoce sont
taillés dans le tuf volcaniques
elles sont creusées aussi dans les
falaises qui borde le ravin mais aussi
elles sont creusées dans des causes
dans des cônes où la circulation se fait
par puits
ainsi il était très facile de se
réfugier de se cacher et de se rendre
invisible
il était aussi très difficile à ce
moment là de prendre ces citadelles dont
l'unique porte se ferme avec une énorme
pierre
la circulation intérieure se fait
verticalement par des cheminées creuser
d'albiol dans lesquels comme l'attestent
ces images se réfugier la vie et
horizontalement par des couloirs que
ferme des roues de pierre comme c'est
énorme que vous voyez sur votre écran
réfectoire du dal monastère
tout est taillée dans la pierre les
câbles les bancs les lits chapelle
et source ô combien précieuse enfouis au
plus profond du sra 4,5 mètres sous
terre
chapelle tombe au tombeau images de
saints ornementations fresque guerrier
et des temps modernes cet homme pour
vous pouvez qu'on en sort
sur la plaine de kenya pour nous cette
tronche
avant d'aborder pamuk al cité
extraordinaire ancienne ville antique de
hierro police ou chaudes jaillit une
source qui transforme tout ce qu'elle
touche en un monde pétrifié
extraordinaire que je livre entièrement
à votre imagination
une
m
où
nous
non
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de solange
péters et d'alain vouliez montage pierre
michel rey script charlotte de la salle
sont annick v10 illustration sonore
dominic palladini